my
hello my name is amy lawler and i'm
noelle
yee and we'll be going to the flame
festival in georgia this
april 12th to the 15th
i'll be teaching a intermediate contact
staff class
a contact club class and a poi
class focusing on one-handed poi and
some other simple techniques
and i'll be teaching a flow wand class a
contact staff dance class
and most likely a beginner contact staff
class as well
the festival is it near atlanta yeah so
about
100 miles like lafayette georgia
how about that one so if you're flying
in you probably want to go to the
atlanta airport but
if you're around the area at all you
should definitely make it out
the plank is taking off right now
oh me
you